hello sandals I would benefit them or  the board of directors for here the 2015  Norway chess when you think at the end  of this tournament that it will be  successful what are your goals of  success with this event we want to make  sure the players are happy and we also  would like people to remember or feel  like Dave went to a tournament that was  kind of different from a tournament  they've been to before lovely that's why  I like taking our players outside the  hotel at least for a couple of rounds  yes we planted well so we haven't had  any problems and Benedict thank you so  very much thank you thank you and good  luck for the rest of the tournament all  right that was Benedict from the board  of directors here at Norway chess 2015  back to you in the studios in st. Louis  you